Westworld Season 2 Episode 1 – what happens,
and what does it mean?
We see Bernard during the massacre that Dolores
started last season.
The host Rebus is shooting at a guest, just
like the guests had been shooting at him.
With Dolores’ robot rebellion, hosts are
getting bloody revenge on humanity.
Bernard is hiding with Charlotte, and some
guests from the Delos corporate board.
A friendly stable boy host comes in, and the
guests kill him because they don’t trust
any robot . Bernard is a robot, so he’ll
have to keep that secret to stay safe around
humans.
On the way to an outpost, the guests are killed
by Angela and the masked men, who are working
for Dolores in her role as the villain Wyatt.
Charlotte and Bernard escape to a secret Delos
lab, where drone hosts are working on… something.
There were hints last season that Delos has
a “secret project” in Westworld . Apparently,
this involves recording Westworld “guests'
experiences and their DNA” . That kind of
data would be valuable.
Rich and powerful people come to Westworld
, and if Delos has video footage of them killing
and fucking in the park, they could blackmail
powerful people for political influence – like
some kinda pee tape situation . And with guest
DNA, Delos could clone people.
The 1976 Westworld sequel Futureworld has
Delos replacing world leaders with robot clones.
So maybe Delos plans to use this data and
DNA to blackmail and replace people to…
y’know, take over the world.
Charlotte asks Delos to come rescue them from
the robots, but Delos refuses until Charlotte
delivers Peter Abernathy . Last season, Charlotte
loaded Peter’s brain with important data
– maybe it’s this experience and DNA data.
Charlotte tried to smuggle Pete to Delos,
but he didn’t make it.
So now, Charlotte needs to find Abernathy
and get him to Delos, so that Charlotte can
escape and Delos can advance their plan.
But maybe Dolores will get involved here – because
Abernathy is her host father.
We see inside a host’s head, and their brain
is like an egg or pearl thing.
Inside that is some red juice, which might
relate to this red nano stuff we saw in the
trailer.
Bernard’s having problems with his brain
– probably because he shot himself last
season.
His cortical shield is damaged , so he’s
leaking brain fluid out his ear.
He’s shaking, and confused, and nearly dies,
until he takes brain fluid from another host
and injects it to himself, like some kind
of robot vampire.
This is probably just a temporary fix – maybe
he needs the help of Elsie for repairs.
Earlier in the episode, we see Bernard wake
up on a beach with Delos forces Karl Strand,
Antoine and Maling.
This stuff actually happens two weeks after
the bits with Charlotte and Dolores’ massacre.
Bernard is “unstuck in time” , and has
flashbacks of stuff that may have happened
over the last couple weeks – future episodes
might fill in these blanks.
Strand’s men are mopping up after Dolores’
uprising.
They execute hosts , which disturbs Bernard.
He’s sympathetic to his fellow robots.
And yet here he is helping the humans.
So Bernard feels deeply “conflicted” . Strand
talks to some Chinese military guys, and says
“[their] country” has given Delos control
over “this … island” . This seems to
confirm that Westworld is an island on Earth,
probably near China.
The Finnish subtitles of the Season 1 finale
give coordinates to a place in the South China
Sea called Mischief Reef , where in the real
world China is building artificial islands
. So this seems to be the true location of
Westworld.
Stubbs turns up, which is mysterious, cause
last we saw him, he was captured by hosts
from Ghost Nation.
How did he escape?
What did Ghost Nation want?
Why is no one talking about Stubbs’ disappearance?
It seems suspicious.
Bernard goes with Strand to look for missing
hosts.
They find a Bengal tiger, wandered across
from Park 6 . Park 1 is Westworld, and Shogun
World seems to be Park 2 – so what’s Park
6?
Well Bengal tigers are from India.
And a Reddit user found a hidden image on
a Westworld site that says Rajworld , maybe
meaning the Rajasthan region of India.
So maybe Park 6 is an Indian themed park – with
tigers.
Strand tracks the hosts to a place called
Western Valley . And they find the Valley
has inexplicably changed to a sea.
Ford had used terraforming technology to shape
the land in Westworld, but Stubbs says they
would’ve noticed if Ford had made this sea
while he was alive . And the water is full
of hosts, including what looks like Teddy.
Bernard says that he killed all these hosts
. But how would Bernard do that, and why?
This might connect to Dolores.
At the start of the episode, we see Dolores
with Arnold – the human from thirty years
ago who robot Bernard is based on.
Or maybe this is just Bernard in a vision
or something.
Either way BernArnold tells her he had dream
he was “on an ocean”, and Dolores had
“left [him] behind”, and “the waters
were rising around [him]” – which sounds
like this flooded valley.
BernArnold says he’s “frightened of what
[Dolores] might become” . And in this episode,
Dolores becomes an anime supervillain.
She guns down fleeing people, slowly executes
random humans, and gives a speech about the
“reckoning” . She dehumanises her human
victims the same way humans dehumanised hosts,
calling them “things” , with “drive”s
and “cornerstone”s.
Dolores says she feels conflicted between
different roles – she has the optimism and
compassion of Dolores, but also the cynicism
and brutality of Wyatt.
Wyatt was a bad guy character who Arnold merged
with Dolores thirty years ago.
Dolores wants to reject the Wyatt and Dolores
roles, and evolve into a new person . But
so far, Dolores is mostly just acting like
Wyatt.
She’s murdering random people, working with
Angela and the masked men, and talks about
taking over the world . Wyatt was the same.
He wanted to “claim this earth or raze it
to the ground” . So is Dolores truly free,
or is she still following her programming
as Wyatt?
Dolores says she remembers everything, and
that she has a special destiny with Teddy
. How does that connect to Teddy’s drowning
in the valley?
We see Dolores kill a host, and say “not
all of us deserve to make it to the valley
beyond” . The stable boy mentions riding
for “the valley beyond” . And Rebus mentions
“the journey” . Is Dolores leading the
hosts on a “journey” to the flooded “valley”?
Is this part of the Wyatt storyline?
Wyatt seems like a Colonel Kurtz culty kinda
cunt – he’s got “strange ideas”, “Forces
his men to wear the … flesh of their enemies”,
and his followers “do anything for him”
. Maybe Dolores is planning a mass death Jonestown
thing in the flooded valley.
Dolores says it ends with Teddy, and Teddy’s
surname is Flood.
The flood could connect to the Biblical flood,
where God wipes out humanity for being unworthy
– like how Dolores is killing unworthy humans.
But why would Dolores kill all these hosts?
Showrunner Jonathon Nolan says host “brains
don’t require oxygen” – so can hosts
even drown?
Are these hosts really dead?
The flooding of the valley is very mysterious.
But it seems connected to Dolores and Wyatt
and Teddy and Bernard.
William, the Man in Black, emerges from corpses.
He looks at that wolf that keeps turning up
at massacres.
This wolf is one of the most baffling mysteries
in Westworld, no one knows what it means.
Is it a symbol of death, consciousness, humanity?
Or just a cute doggo that likes dead people?
Maybe we’ll find out later on.
William heads to a safehouse, and ends up
in a brutal fight with some hosts.
He kills them with gun and knife, then treats
his wound, grunting and bleeding, then – he
smiles.
Cause this violence and pain is what William
wants.
He calls it “fun” . He’s almost like
a darker version of Saitama in One Punch Man
– someone who has power and freedom but
no purpose, so uses violence to distract himself
from existential boredom . Westworld is set
in the future – maybe as technology and
prosperity make modern life easier , people
lose the conflict and struggle that gives
life meaning.
So William seeks ever more challenge and violence
. He meets Robert, the robot version of a
young Robert Ford.
And Robert speaks to William with Ford’s
voice, congratulating him for finishing the
Maze goose chase last season, and giving him
a new quest – to “find the door”.
To “make it back out”.
Does this mean for William to escape the Westworld
park?
Or is it more metaphorical?
Robert says “The game begins where you end
… and ends where you began” , so maybe
William will go back to his past with Dolores,
and Logan.
Robert says “Everything is code here”
– code because people speak in cryptic metaphor,
and because hosts are programmed with computer
code – which reflects the connection between
secrets and control in this show.
And then William shoots the kid on the face,
because– Westworld, and also to show that
Robert Ford is finally truly dead.
There’s no robot decoy, no horcrux, no senzu
bean.
Ford’s gone for good – at least until
HBO gets Hopkins back for some flashbacks.
In the Mesa Hub, Sizemore is attacked by a
host that he designed back in Season 1.
He’s terrorised by lines that he wrote.
He’s saved by Maeve who has the power to
control other hosts.
They find the park control room’s been wiped
out – though it’s not clear who did this.
Bernard’s flashback suggests that we’ll
learn more.
Maeve recruits Sizemore to help her find her
daughter . Sizemore says Maeve’s daughter
isn’t real – she’s just a robot that
was programmed to be her daughter . Maeve
argues that she is artificial, but she still
has thoughts and feelings and the power to
splatter Sizemore on the walls . This argument
over realness connects back to Dolores and
BernArnold’s conversation, and the idea
that something is “real” when it’s “irreplaceable”
– like, the robots of Westworld can be rebuilt
and replaced, whereas a human is unique.
The irony is that Bernard is a robot replacement
of Arnold.
There are whole closets full of spare Bernards
– so is Bernard not real?
And since Arnold was replaced – was Arnold
not real?
The technology of Westworld breaks down the
line between real and not-real.
As far as Maeve cares, she loves her daughter,
so she goes to find her.
Let’s hope she doesn’t find a closet full
of daughters, cause that sorta philosophy
quandary could really ruin a reunion.
On the rooftop, Maeve reunites with Hector,
who was her sidekick in the rebellion last
season.
Hector doesn’t care that Maeve left him
for dead, he’s just happy to follow her.
So there’s a sort of romance between Maeve
and Hector, but is Hector acting of his own
free will?
Maeve has the power to control other hosts
– and she fiddled with Hector’s programming.
So is Hector’s loyalty real?
How is any relationship real if you can control
the people around you?
How might this affect Maeve’s relationship
with her daughter?
Maeve makes Sizemore strip naked – just
like the Westworld techs strip hosts naked
. Like Rebus and Dolores, Maeve is making
humans suffer the same way humans made hosts
suffer.
And there is a sort of justice to that.
But last season, there was hope that the hosts
would choose to be better and nobler than
humanity . Doesn’t killing and hurting make
them just as bad as us?
This season explores “the birth of a new
people.
And the choices they … make”.
What choices will Dolores, Maeve and Bernard
make to shape the destiny of this new robot
people?
In Season 1, Ford compares robot-human war
to the conflict between humans and Neanderthals
forty thousand years ago . This is a story
told in Sapiens, by Yuval Harari.
The book is a quick history of our species
– from the evolution of consciousness, to
language, religion, money, agriculture.
science, all explained clearly and accessibly.
You can listen to Sapiens for free today by
signing up for a trial at audible.com/asx.
Membership gives you a free book each month,
and if you cancel, you keep the books.
You can listen in the car or the gym or in
a secret cloning bunker while you hide from
Skynet.
Help out Alt Shift X, and get a free book,
by signing up with our sponsor at audible.com/asx,
or text asx to 500-500.
Shout out to the redditors and podcasters
who figure out these hidden Westworld puzzles,
and thank you to the Patrons who support Alt
Shift X, including zachary w Sullivan, Lyndey
Kelly, Dana Born, Robbie Gall, Alex PD, and
Checo.
Cheers.